he's big he's wooden and he makes one
thing perfectly clear he is Groot
Marvel's talking tree has taken the
world by storm
despite as minimal vocabulary but few
know his story in its entirety from the
alien a Buress to the terrifying
termites
this is Groot backstory movie-going
audiences across the galaxy know him as
a hero but believe it or not Groot began
his career on the comic book page as a
bad guy he made his debut in 1960s tales
to astonish issue 13 where he was billed
as the monster from Planet X and like a
lot of the baddies in Marvel's monster
comics he initially meets an ironic end
when he lands on earth the Groot
encounters a biologist named Leslie
Evans who study focuses bugs he might
seem outclassed by a giant talking tree
and his army a fellow flora colossi but
he winds up being humanity's secret
weapon despite being a seemingly
invulnerable giant bent on conquering
earth Groot is still made of wood and
winds up being laid low by one of the
most destructive forces on the planet
termites after thus he descended into
the same kind of obscurity as a lot of
the other monsters with names like Ram
boo or Moomba who took up shelf space in
Marvel's pre superhero monster comics he
would reappear occasionally and
encountered the Hulk in 1976 alongside
five other marble monsters Groot in
particular is defeats him when the hawk
beats him to splinters with a couple of
rocks effective but significantly less
clever than termites beyond that his
best-known appearance came in an issue
of sensational spider-man when he was
the subject of one of Peter Parker's
nightmares that makes sense too for a
born-and-bred New Yorker who needs
skyscrapers to swing from what would be
scarier than a big old tree Kreutz has
had a few diversions on his journey from
monstrous antagonist to heroic movie
star as you might expect
it's an old branching back story with
its roots and some pretty weird comics
you might be surprised to learn that he
was actually once an agent of shield as
revealed in the pages of 2006 s Nick
Fury's Howling Commandos in this story
the Howling Commandos are a group of
monstrous villains
constructed by fury to fight that fellow
forces of evil
fury uses his recruitment pitch on a
version of crews that still has a spree
Guardians evil tendencies and convinces
him to join his elite team of cryptids
myths and
monsters his compatriots include
Bigfoot's Frankenstein a vampire a
werewolf and a man trapped in a gorillas
body among others together they team up
with the son of Satan and save Earth
from an attack by Merlin the wizard from
Camelot
now that's the story we'd like to see
make its way to the MCU another weird
adventure that was every bit as strange
as a stint in the holding commandos came
when crew two rockets encountered venom
yes that venom spider-man's brain eating
former costume turned felon from beyond
the stars in 2014 guardians of the
galaxy issue 21 found groot taken over
by the symbiotes fortunately Drax tears
a pair apart before I can really bond
with Groot never getting beyond the
surface it seems that this time a venom
was all bark
despite being vast and infinite Marvel's
version of outer space is actually a
pretty small world it was really only a
matter of time before Groot had a run-in
with the Kree one of Marvel's most
prominent alien empires their powerful
militaristic and don't tend to take
things lightly so naturally our favorite
wooden misfit clashes with their
worldview the annihilation conquest
storyline that kick-started groots
ascent to popularity finds the Kree in
the midst of yet another universe
spanning war this time against the
robotic hive Minds called the Phalanx
when the time comes for the Kree to
recruit a Shaggy space pirates and give
him a team of also-rans to stop a
galactic apocalypse they pour groot out
of space jail and throw him into battle
with some other d-list Marvel
obscurities that might seem a little
more familiar these days than they were
in 2007 Peter quill Drax rocket racoon
and Gamora fruits years of languishing
in obscurity were pretty and remarkable
but as Marvel as shown us time and time
again even the most obscure weirdo on
their roster is only one story away from
being a superstar Ferg roots that
happened in 2007 when he was brought
back to annihilation conquest as a
member of a team of misfits that would
evolve into the guardians of the galaxy
rather than the world conquering monster
Groot was reimagined as a more
empathetic hero with a smaller
vocabulary
yes said that according to the 2013
guardians of the galaxy comic Groot
comes from a noble branch of the family
destined for great power and position
sadly he's not a match for the culture
of Planet X and its rulers the arbor
masters disagreeing with their tendency
towards kidnapping and experimenting on
other sentient creatures ultimately
Groot is exiled when he defends one of
the maintenance mammals looked down upon
by his brethren and their masters thus
begins his journey throughout space and
ultimately to the guardians of the
galaxy druten rocky racoon had instant
chemistry with each other once they were
on the same team becoming fast friends
as alluded to in the film's Rocket is a
result of a bleak program of animal
experimentation and grew to start has
always been moved by the plight of the
powerless takes a liking to rocket
immediately of course it helps the
rocket unlike most sentient creatures
can understand his speech Rocket Raccoon
takes his role as Kreutz best friend
seriously more than once he's rescued
Groot after the tree creature was killed
since crew can be regrown from small
slivers rocket will often collect a
small shard of his fallen friend and
replant him caring for him until he's
grown in this sense the furry friends a
little like Planet X's Arbor masters but
unlike them he loves crude for who he is
and considers his compassion and assets
instead of a liability check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about Marvel
characters are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and at the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]